el chocolate se toma a parís por espacio
de un fin de semana la idea de este
salón es la de caminar entre los cientos
de stands que muestran las diferentes
preparaciones los diferentes tipos de
chocolate algunas incluso de con sabores
bastante particulares pero más allá de
esto también se trata de un viaje a
través del mundo de quienes lo preparan
la característica de este cacao chuncho
y los granos de cacao es que incluso se
pueden consumir lo que se conoce como
roe kaká o el cacao crudo sin tostar y
para ello yo les puedo hacer una
demostración simplemente se se quita
la cáscara
yo puedo comérmelo y disfrutar
cuando uso el prueba el chocolate a la
primera probada usted dice guau qué es
esto porque no es amargo incluso a veces
la gente me pregunta si esto de
chocolate o si este yo les digo no el
chocolate pero hay una manera especial
de cocinarlo además de las degustaciones
y de los diferentes concursos la idea de
este salón también es demostrar que el
chocolate es algo muy noble con el cual
además pueden incluso hacerse obras de
arte hay varias esculturas en diferentes
stands de animales incluso de gárgolas
como las que hay en otro dame de parís
una en relieve de napoleón bonaparte
pero quizás la que más impacto ha
causado es la que está justamente a mis
espaldas se trata de esta réplica del
guernica de picasso para esta obra se
necesitaron 500 kilogramos de chocolate
y fue fabricada por artesanos
chocolateros de francia y de españa